there's been a lot of news this week and
sometimes it's so hard to keep up with
some of the offbeat stories it's a good
thing we have carly shempkins here
she's a reporter for fox news headlines
24-7 carly my friend what you got
okay let's kick things off with more
criticism of old movies turner classic
movies launching a new series that will
explore the
troubling and problematic aspect of old
hollywood movies
18 different films will be put under the
microscope including breakfast at
tiffany's gone with the wind and psycho
a panel of experts will discuss the
movie's potentially upsetting moments
including depictions of racism and
sexism
turner classic movie host jacqueline
stewart says the goal is to have
deeper and longer conversations that
will enrich the
viewers experience of the film so
they're not being canceled lawrence but
they are being re-examined
how do you how do you have the
conversation that the movie is no longer
original i think it's
well whatever um i think it's pretty
nice yeah well let me let me just say i
think that sometimes these conversations
can be beneficial but the argument
against psycho is going a little bit far
they're going to
examine how transgender identity and a
man dressing up as a woman is linked to
violence and mental health i think the
fact that the guy was living with his
dead skeleton mom
makes him crazy not the fact that he was
wearing the dress
oh but meantime i got to get to this
president biden raising eyebrows during
a congratulatory conference call
with the nasa engineers responsible for
landing the
mars perseverance rover take a listen
this is an incredible honor
and it's amazing indian of dissent
americans are taking over the country
you my vice president my speechwriter
when i i tell you what but thank you you
guys are incredible
okay so the president went on to
describe diversity as an american
strength but the attempt at levity being
called
tone deaf by some critics i'm telling
this guy is a gaff machine
it's always something happening anyway
so i will can't get enough of president
trump
just can't get enough that's right
california congressman eric swalwell is
suing
president trump in an attempt to hold
him financially responsible for the
january 6th riot now suawell
accusing the president of terrorizing
lawmakers and causing
him emotional distress the civil suit
also names the president's son
donald trump jr rudy giuliani and
congressman mo brooks
all who spoke at the january 6th rally a
trump senior advisor jason miller
ripping into swalwell in a statement to
fox news
calling him a low life with no
credibility who got caught dating a
chinese spy so
then definitely fighting words yeah
carly what's the latest on that
of him going around with a spy we still
haven't gotten any briefing on that or
anything
yeah and i think that this lawsuit is
definitely a
long shot considering you can always
make that free speech
claim it seems like this is more about
eric swalwell getting some points in the
media
and getting media attention and twitter
attention than
it being really anything very serious
carla you know what i think it is they
just can't get enough of donald trump oh
no no they want yeah they're one of them
relive those glory days of 2016 to 2020.
they they need content and if you're in
the media or if you're even a politician
it was so much
free material yeah he's the trump model
is the business model now let's just be
honest about it
you're right about that my friend
thank you so much my friend for joining
me today oh thanks lauren great job
and and thank you so much for watching
fox news primetime it has been a
fabulous week i
want to thank the camera crew my
producers i couldn't have done it
without you guys
and you know who's gonna be here next
week trey gowdy thank you so much for
joining me this week
i love you guys and i'll see you guys
next week monday fox and friends
i'm lawrence jones and tucker crossing
is up next